And now to you, Scoutmaster.
During one of my recent hikes I just I had to laugh at the mountains because they're hilarious:
Hill areas,
Hill areas- Okay,
Yeah,
That was a bit of a reach, but most of these are.
This is podcast number 256..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green, And this week I've got
some email questions to answer, And you know what I'm going to do just that. So let's
get started, shall we? I received this email from an assistant Scoutmaster and
committee member- and I'll just keep their name out of the picture here, But they
wrote saying the troop I am involved with is on the verge of complete
collapse. You can probably guess the reasons, But from my perspective, they
start and end with the Scoutmaster and committee chair being overtaxed, largely
due to their refusal to delegate any responsibilities. This makes them kind of
cranky. They don't use patrols, They don't allow the Scouts to plan, lead,
control or become engaged in any of those types of things. The Scoutmaster
decides all the events, the dates, the meals, he shops for the meals, He's
the advancement chair, the camping chair, the treasurer, et cetera, et cetera,
and he's also deeply involved with several different roles in the Cub
pack. Okay, I'm going to stop before I go on, because I want to answer one
thing that I frequently get emails about, and that is multiple roles in
scouting. Don't Just don't do it. Take on one principal role. You know
you're going to help with a lot of other things, I understand that, But
don't take on the principal responsibility for anything beyond one principal
role. If you're going to be a Scoutmaster, be a Scoutmaster. If you're
going to be a committee chair, be a committee chair. If you're going to be
an assistant Scoutmaster, be an assistant Scoutmaster. Don't do three
or four things at once, especially across a couple of different
units. It denies other people the opportunity to come in and join in
as a volunteer and it's bad for Scouts. In the end, it's bad for Scouts.
Now, usually the argument that I get back is: well, nobody else will
volunteer. Well, of course they won't. If you're doing everything,
why would they? You have to stop doing things that other
volunteers should be doing, And if everything comes to a screeching
halt, people will kind of go: oh, I guess somebody needs to take
on some responsibilities. But if you feel it is your responsibility,
and only your responsibility, to make sure everything is done
and you don't particularly like working with other people and
the way they do them, you are headed for the land of burnout.
Don't do it to yourself, Don't do it to your Scouts. One role is
good More than one role not so great. Okay, just thought that
that might be useful advice. Let's go on with this email. Both
the Scoutmaster and the committee chair of our troop have
expressed to me that they feel like they're done. They're
not having fun anymore And they actually just planned to
shut the troop down and call it a day. They say that I am
a potential future Scoutmaster, but I'm just not ready yet And
my initial reaction is to agree. I have all the position
training, but I've been in the troop for under a year. I was
involved with our pack for two years And I lack experience.
So right now I am wondering if I should just find a new
troop, because this one is imploding, or talk them into
allowing me to try to run the troop. So my question to
you is: am I ready? What is your experience with a new
Scoutmaster with little experience being able to
successfully manage a troop of Scouts? We have 10 or 12 Scouts
right now, with maybe five or seven weeblos who say they
would join if the current Scoutmaster left? Am I foolish
to try this, or would it be better for all the Scouts
involved to send them to other troops? Well, that's a
very fair question And to begin answering it, I want to
tell you a story. I took over as the Scoutmaster for
our troop when I was in my early 20s. I did not have a
whole lot of experience as a Scout And the second or
third year we were at summer camp. the camp director
took me aside and asked me if I had a couple of weeks
free that summer to come down and help him by
directing the archery range for the remainder of
the summer. Now I was flattered because I had a
lot of respect for this camp director and I love the
camp program and being on the staff would be great fun.
I told him. I said: you know, that sounds like a
really great time, but I don't know very much about
archery. And he looked at me and he said: you know
what you'll do? fine, I'll give you a merit badge
book. All you have to do is stay 15 minutes ahead
of the Scouts. And I thought to myself: well, yeah,
that seems reasonable. I took up his offer. I
stayed 15 minutes ahead of the Scouts. It wasn't all
that difficult to learn the skills that I needed
And I ended up working at the camp for a dozen or
more years and also served in the camp director
position. So if you're concerned about having a
whole lot of experience to be able to take over as
the Scout Master of a Scout Troop, no, don't
worry about it, You'll do fine, especially in
comparison to the burned out Scouters that you'll
be replacing. Expertise and experience is
always a good thing to have, but it is entirely
overrated in a lot of ways. Scouts need someone
with energy and vision to help them be Scouts,
And they don't care what you know, They respond
to who you are. I'm going to say that again: They
don't care what you know, They respond to who
you are. So let's accept the idea that there
could be a lot of people with a lot more
experience who would certainly look better on
paper for the job. but it doesn't. but
experience, expertise, training, all of those
things- Okay, they're pretty solid indicators,
but they're not the single most important
thing, which is that kind of expansive vision
and the energy and the interest in learning
as you go along and making it work for Scouts-
Another indication that you're a solid candidate
for it is. you do possess the humility
required to actually learn from experiences.
because you're already asking this question,
You see what I mean. If you thought that, oh
yeah, well, this will just be a walk in the
park, I can, anybody can- do this,
Then I might not be as confident in my
advice, but I know anyone with the vision
and the energy to do so can rise to this
challenge. You'll make plenty of mistakes,
but those are really the joy of it all.
Figuring all this out is the most fun
part, and you'll learn as you go and
you'll have fun doing it, and your Scouts
will be learning right beside you.
So don't let this troop fold up.
Step up, Do what you can,
Who you are, your energy and your vision
is much more important than any level of
experience or expertise you may have,
And I'm going to say this too: that
what most experienced Scouts believe
to be crucially important
is often just window dressing.
The simple, most obvious things in Scouting
are often missed and devalued.
Aim at making it possible for Scouts to
go camping with their friends, and
everything else that we want to have
happen will follow. Don't aim at
administrative excellence, Don't aim
at any of the other window dressing.
Get Scouts out camping with their
friends, Put your energy there,
Make that your vision and things
will start to come together.
You are in an ideal situation
if both the Scoutmaster and the
committee chair say that they're
going to step out of the picture
Because you do not need them around
telling you how to burn yourself out,
just like they did. I would just say
thank you very much and
thank them for having served
the troop and get them out of the
way. turn to the work at hand.
The only other piece of advice I have
for you is to recruit a committee
chair right away you can work with-
And my guess is
you probably already have a couple of candidates
in mind. And I want to repeat:
what most experienced Scouters believe
is really important is not,
It's really just the window dressing
of the program. Don't be distracted
by their experience or their square knots.
What you're told is important
at training events and by the literature
and by Scouters who believe
their experts tends to obscure
rather than reveal the simplicity
and directness of the Scouting
program. And I should
mention the advice that I
extend in that wise also
applies to what you hear from me.
If it works, it works If it doesn't
move on. And I leave you
with this bit of advice
from Baden Powell:
The Scoutmasters job is like
golf or scything
or fly fishing:
If you press, you don't get there,
At least not with
anything like the extent you do
with a lighthearted,
effortless swing.
But you've got to swing, It's no use
standing still.
This next email comes to me from Jody,
who's the parent of a Scout,
and they asked this:
I have a sticky situation with our Scoutmaster.
My son made life rank two years ago.
His Eagle project is done,
The paperwork is completed,
His application is signed.
The Scoutmaster, however, refuses
to have a Scoutmaster
conference for Eagle Scout or put the date
on the application because,
according to him, my son
has not recently been active enough.
My son has already served
in a position of responsibility for six months,
but the Scoutmaster is not going to sign off
until January because
he insists he must have a current position
of responsibility.
My son worked hard to get to this point
and being held off at the last minute, like this,
does not seem right or fair.
Is the Scoutmaster allowed
to do this? And if they are not,
what is my recourse?
Well, Jody, this is
a simple answer, and
I'm sorry you find yourself in this situation.
although this kind of situation
is distressingly not unfamiliar,
The Scoutmaster's behavior
in this case is misdirected
and it's counter to what's expected
of him. So I'll spend a couple of minutes
in a quick review for everyone
on exactly how this works, because
this kind of an ambush usually happens
when
somebody has reservations about an Eagle candidate
having served actively
in a position of responsibility
or having been active
in his troop and patrol during the
period of time he was a life Scout.
Now there is no
excuse for
Scouters to ambush a Scout
over these issues this late in the game.
So, as we know, to move from
life to Eagle you have to have
tenure in a position of responsibility
and you have to have tenure as an active
member of your troop and patrol.
Enough time goes by in either of those
propositions that a
Scouter who is concerned
that that activity is not sufficient
to fulfill the requirement
for the next rank
needs to be talking to the Scout
as soon as that concern
becomes apparent to them. They cannot
and should not
wait until we get to this
point and have them issue
a judgment that says:
well, you haven't been active enough and you haven't
fulfilled your position of responsibility.
So what about this scenario where they were active
for the
specific tenure required
to move up to Eagle and they were active
in a position of responsibility, but it was a while
back. it still counts. They do not
have to be currently
active. They've already banked all that activity
and you can't zero out their account.
So there's two problems here. So we
must not ambush
Scouts, because any concerns about
their level of activity or
how they are fulfilling a position of
responsibility should be addressed as soon
as those concerns become apparent,
Not six months down the line, not two and a half
years down the line. And this is all
in the Guide to Advancement. It's not that
hard to understand And
the recourse in this situation
is reasonably straightforward and it is
also outlined in the Guide to Advancement
In
section ready. Here you
go, Pencils up:
8.0.,
3.2,
3.2.,
4.0.,
5.0.
6.0.
7.0.
8.0.
9.0.
10.0.
11.0.
12.0.
13.0.,
14.0.,
15.0.,
16.0.
17.0.,
18.0.,
19.0.
20.0.
21.0.
22.0.
23.0.,
24.0.
25.0.,
26.0.,
27.0.,
28.0.,
29.0.
30.0.
31.0.
32.0.
33.0.
34.0.
35.0.,
36.0.,
37.0.,
38.0.,
39.0.
40.0.
31.0.
32.0.
33.0.,
34.0.,
35.0.,
36.0.,
39.0.,
34.0.
35.0.,
26.0.,
27.0.,
28.0..
past or outside of scouting. Is this a judgment call or is there a hard and fast BSA national
rule we can refer to If it's a judgment call. I would imagine that could get difficult differentiating
from one merit badge to the next and one scout to the next. And the second part of my question is:
if past work is permitted, what's the standard of proof? I hate to use the word proof, so perhaps
verification for a scout to be credited for the requirement, A note from a coach or a teacher,
hard copies of reports or presentations, photographs of the work that they did.
is there a standard for proof? Well, Tom, those are two very interesting questions,
and all that one needs to know about advancement policy and merit badges is in the extraordinarily
well-written guide to advancement I referred to earlier in the podcast. Look in the podcast
notes for links directly to a couple of things that I think help answer your question. The first is
a section titled about the application for merit badge, or something as better known as the blue
card, and, to quote from that section, it says it is the counselor's decision whether to accept
work or activities completed prior to the issuing of the signed blue card, and notes that common
sense should prevail. So it is the counselor's decision whether to accept work or activities
completed prior to the beginning of the merit badge. it's pretty simple. it's something that
is a judgment call on the part of the counselor, who is making any number of judgment calls
in counseling the merit badge and fulfilling requirements. anyway, it's not a sticky situation
at all. it's up to the counselor. The other thing that touches on this is fulfilling
more than one requirement with a single activity. there's a section on that in the guide to advancement
and I'll have a link to that in the podcast notes. Now, when we talk about judgment calls, there's no
reason that a merit badge counselor or another scouter should make a judgment call about what
a scout has done on their own. Our work is developing character and this is a great
opportunity to do just that. We ought to make the most of the opportunity to apply the scout
oath and law to these types of situations, and here's an example of exactly what I mean. if I was
counseling a merit badge and a scout came to me and we were looking at requirements and the scout
said: you know I already did that- I'd ask them to read the requirement very carefully out loud, so
we both understood exactly what was required, and then I would ask them to explain to me how
they fulfilled that requirement specifically, step by step. So after we did that, I would ask them
if they still believe that the activity they described to me after reading the requirement
fulfilled what the requirement asked of them. So I'm not going to impose my judgment on the scout.
I am going to seek out how they judge the situation. they may be able to explain better
to me exactly what the situation is and I may end up agreeing with them. or, if I disagree with them,
we're going to figure out how they fulfill that requirement in an equitable manner that credits
them for any of the past work that they've done perhaps, but still makes it work, and we both leave
that conversation happy. If I handle this correctly, the scout's going to leave the conversation
convinced the whole thing was his idea in the first place, because that's usually exactly
how it goes. I'll also note what I said before. I have the scout read the requirement out loud
and then we kind of break the requirement down, because some of them are pretty complicated. so we
kind of break it down into distinct tasks or pieces of knowledge that they have to fulfill,
and that usually makes it pretty obvious whether they've actually fulfilled the requirement or not.
Tom asked: if the work's permitted, then what is the standard of proof or verification for
the scout to get credit? Well, I believe that the standard of proof and verification is the
first point in the scout law: that a scout is trustworthy. they're not going to lie about
something or misrepresent themselves in order to get credit for a merit badge requirement. because if
being trustworthy doesn't mean something in this situation, it doesn't mean anything anywhere else.
so if a scout asked me to sign off on a requirement that I have not seen them complete,
I asked them once again: read the requirement, explain fully how they did each separate part
of the requirement. if I think they're hedging or, you know, trying to misrepresent what's going
on, I just keep asking questions. if they haven't fulfilled the requirement, it becomes pretty obvious
and I usually don't have to tell them. if they haven't, we'll figure out how they're going to
fulfill the requirement and we'll talk about it again soon. and always before I sign the
requirement, I say: look, I trust what you've told me because you're a scout and we both
understand before I sign that this is really a matter of your personal honor and I don't want
to sign this if you're not 100% sure that I should. like I said, if the scout law doesn't mean something
in this instance, it's meaningless everywhere else. so I have to say that, as a scout master, I paid
as close to zero attention to merit badges as I possibly could. I regarded them- as I do most
things about advancement- as really none of my business. this is something that it's up to a scout
for themselves. scouts would bring me blue cards to sign before starting and I always did after,
asking them who the counselor was, but beyond that I had as little to do with that process as possible.
we stopped having merit badges as the focus of troop meetings or outings years and years and
years ago. we don't really keep track of who's doing what merit badge or anything in that wise.
our scouts manage their own merit badge paperwork. they find their own counselors and they bring
us signed blue cards when they're done. and I have honestly very little idea of how they do that
and I've always been surprised by the amount of merit badge work our scouts do, despite our
kind of laissez faire attitude that we're not really promoting doing merit badges. we don't really
care whether you do them or not, and we're certainly not going to manage any piece of the process
other than taking the blue card and making sure you get the badge. so, one way or another,
it doesn't seem that it's been all that difficult for them to find registered counselors,
nor to finish the work on the badges. outside of troop meetings and camping, I've even gone so far
is when we've gone down to summer camp. you know, let's say: look, don't spend all your time doing
merit badges, do something fun for you know, just like build a fort, go on a hike, hang out.
you don't have to do eight hours of merit badge work every day. I haven't had a whole lot of
scouts take me up on that, by the way. well, that's the email questions I have to answer for this podcast.
if you have a question, it's easy to get in touch with me. I am always available at Clark
at scoutmastercgcom. that's CLA RKE at scoutmastercgcom. I want to thank all the folks who are
backers and patrons and make the podcast possible. if you'd like to be a backer or a patron, just
go to scoutmastercgcom and click the support link at the top of the page and all that remains for us
to do is to hear from our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert, good luck to you and good camping.
why? thank you, sir? until next time, everyone.